this might be the grunty of games I've
ever played in my goddamn life
hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to drunk foo or drunk through
masters or something like that I don't
know I'm gonna try to figure this out
uh yeah Hale and pink on the brink of
death which is what I want that the only
thing I can customize here uh-oh here we
go
yeah leather shorts seem about right
fabulous sneakers okay I'll go with that
all right looks good to be I think okay
anyway so welcome to drum true this game
is on gamejolt for free right now and it
appealed to me because it seemed to be
just a bunch of drunk people having a
brawl but I have no idea how to play so
I'm going to try I'm gonna try to bring
this down a little bit such that you
know I'm actually able to learn
something or two about this are you guys
fighting already
fight are you fighting okay sorry I
could've barely
I barely grabbed a stool for some reason
step stepping my way around all right
then I'm gonna swirl off into the
distance fill my me at all I don't know
what button I'm pressing if it's doing
anything but I think this is a kick I
did something no I didn't do anything I
fell on the ground to died so I'm just
spinning spinning look at me go I'm a
delicate ballerina going off into the
distance of the bar hey guys have you
ever tried to give peace a chance
oh man is flailed myself into a coma
don't mind me I literally I'm pressing
every button I know why I'm hi rocketing
now oh okay I found the rocket button
hahaha
it's kind of like a mixture of gang
beasts and just complete ridiculous
business
oh man I'm a runaway okay well I felt
like I did a lot more than it gave me
credit for because I felt like I was
flailing up a storm and yet nothing was
happening right then right okay alright
we try again I guess why where are we
now where are we in a big empty room
ha okay so the bumper is hurt or the
punch button
but uh okay I've got a cartwheel off to
my destiny and then some other buttons I
don't know which I think it changes
randomly on me is the pelvic thrust
button which pretty sure that's a good
maneuver there hi oh my god you can't
beat my rocket pit dude ah are we drunk
or we experimental superpower test
subjects oh my god I'm dead he still
beat me
who beat me who is that playing again
I'll not give this another go I think
I'm getting the hang of it now
okay alright was right trigger do
nothing I'm just gonna lick my fist for
a little bit here okay goodbye goodbye
my people need me
ah they even do have been hurting myself
more than a burden to anybody that
actually needs to be here Shoom okay I
did something I think I knocked him out
yeah okay
I can't al so I can't go too fast with
my alright nevermind so I have the
ability to rock it off into the distance
but it does absolutely no one any good
can I get up and you not me not how do I
get up I'm on the I'm back there on the
floor don't think the other rent boy
alright okay I don't even know huh if
you do this try it again crank for
yourself cuz I feel like if I'm gonna do
anything it's good do last-man-standing
a gift there we go Kuja oh this looks
fun back-alley brawl hell yeah where am
I
I have no idea oh I'm in this corner
over there quite bishop Yuri
fish fury I'm doing something I am
punching people I don't know if it's
good though so I've gotten left and
right feet to control here I seem to be
on the ground if I get up that'd be
that'd be agreeable for me I'm gonna run
off into the distance oh you can press
the left kick for well I guess I'm down
there alright turn the pick no man Last
Man Standing
sure just left myself
[Music]
thank you yeah it's good it's good silly
I mean the controls are just total
[ __ ] across the board but I think I
could forgive us for that for just being
like that like how did you get up there
with just your fists if my fist had
rocket boosters attached to them I'd be
in a different business than you to be
okay well I suck let's try that again
yeah and I'm just gonna go upstairs good
good
oh don't fill down can I get up please
can I please how do I stand up there we
go okay nah it's gonna [ __ ] me dance and
fall over great okay everybody else is
having a good time I'm just gonna try to
meander up these steps
jump can't do it how can I do that how
did humans go up again I'm not like that
I can't tell Vic thrusts my way up there
hey pay me like one of your french girls
on these steps every row tickets for
everybody ha ha ha ha who's the hood
we're still here we are very drunk
I just realized he's drunk two masters
so all these guys are up ducking drunk
all right who's in there huh I got
barstools I ain't afraid of this guy on
the ground here here's be sorry all
right pardon me
hey there what's up buddy you want me to
come behind the bar you want to come out
here and face me like a man or a woman I
did dinner happened in there okay I got
him I did it I don't know how but I get
it so good ring all right
sighs good of a run off into the
distance again oh I'm so scared
Oh God I'm just gonna hide my quarter
and they're never gonna find me oh I
hope I don't get punished over here give
me I'll take a leak Oh contents on this
corner man if you just hit that you can
kick with each feet independently it
just goes towards the books go to the
nearest enemy hell's going on here I'm
the one with the life bar by the way in
case that wasn't having it all right you
know what I'm gonna just gonna assume
that I'm never
get up ever again wag my face into the
ground and shame here can I stand on my
own two feet cuz that's kind of what I'd
be going for you unless my legs are
broken they might be but I'd like to
assume that I get up I hadn't stand up
on that guy's ass for just a bit of a
second and then I'm on a rocket George
this guy oh you got knocked he'll freak
out
how about you new Oh wallop him in the
face all right come on you want another
go of this ah just coming near me I dare
you I double dog dare ya Oh slap see in
your slap jack
oh what's that punches out the rear
punches out though will do B come on get
punched get punched
okay fighting actually was the worst
idea I could've possibly other run away
I'm not going that way I'm pushing horn
on the stick thinking good are you guys
fighting it out okay I'm just good stand
by the egg door hey wait stick your do
ha ha wait dig you're doing huh is my
egg door okay I don't know where my
fists are going but I'm gonna go over
here okay did I hit somebody hope so
don't even try I've got two stools
you've got one you'll never I'm dead
okay I didn't win that [ __ ] got me I
doubt I love a lovely lovely love the
deeds gonna kick my ball nobody be fight
man kicking up a bank I'm trying to kick
my ball my ball my mom hey my ball my
ball guys you a --sold okay I'm dead
I just wanted to kick a ball on you guys
just brought a fine into this I feel
like you're being a little bit you know
damaged Deborah Deborah dating to
society whatever the word is that means
you guys are [ __ ] that's what I'm
trying to say but in fancy talk
okay I think its first two three I gotta
get one more point in you know just good
eye Bobby Dreskin nobody bother me
please hey I said nobody bow nobody I
said nobody bother me please I'm just
gonna go over here you got your apples
I'm going home telling mom can't believe
this [ __ ] hey would you jam Bobby
huh oh come back there's I'm sure you
don't think I won't huh just cuz I'm
dancing in the middle street don't mean
I don't mean business
alright fine I think I caught you got
down your cut of a [ __ ] I'll slap you
in your Jack slap I'll use my rocket
through teleport back to Mom's house
okay yeah you learned your lesson there
don't try to do it god damn it you don't
try well I told you about trying what
mom telling you about trying go huh when
you can give up on your dream to do that
hey hey none oh stop no no please I
wanted to win
good going back to mom time you guys are
just sick phantoms get dumped Easter's
virtually goddamn who put these Mario
64's stairs up here there we go hey you
come up here no my mom oh [ __ ] whoops
okay you know what rocketing into the
into the fray isn't always the best idea
well good thing that stool is very good
for my lumbar support I'm gonna go over
your dress bat mate doctor get out of
you okay never mind then home runs
myself okay alright then just you know I
don't know what I'm doing there I'm just
rubbish go [ __ ] here and play with my
breath can I walk you from across the
town how oh okay thanks I get him yeah I
got how about you gay oh come on you
[ __ ] I'm gonna gotten you it's a
mid-air bat
piccolo I can't see him don't be silly
did you move it fast okay I don't know
what I'm doing right or wrong but
apparently that wasn't it
Judy Joe I'll stand up eventually but
not now boink boink boink how about a
barstool up your buddy that sounds
pleasurable I'm - I'm on the ground now
so you guys say whatever you want about
oh my god how's it fare I'm running away
don't fight me gold old gold
gosh I'm trying to hit someone when
they're down get kicked and off
goddamnit
alright kick okay alright then she done
it so big but don't you total food come
on kick okay miss kick with the wrong
what's there got to get there
punch okay oh that guy phone so punched
him I'm down okay apparently apparently
she punched me back but I didn't see it
happen I'm gonna get you ah my bar
stools are superior ha did it okay I
beat him I did it okay I think I can end
with that one I'm not gonna I know I'll
go to three shebanski oh you think you
can dance away from these fists up
you're right how I see why does it take
my health when I hit them okay and it
doesn't make any goddamn sense I'm
coming for you ah come on I just I've
got what the Frick going on with this
it's so impossible hi whining up a maker
Oh dodged you you think you can dodge
these moves huh okay all right I don't
know what's happening but it's painful
for you and for me to watch job kick
okay never mind then
thinking I was gonna do something and
I'm over here jump kick oh yeah that's
that felt bad ow
stop stop stop it stop it stop it stop
it
can I get up please can I get up let's
jump kick on into the next century with
you huh alright don't worry I'm just
gonna go going to Child's Pose here I
just need to get my yoga and whatever I
can
don't mind the undulation it's just some
part of the yoga yeah ah yeah I really
want to be the world class twerker you
know what I mean I just got to work on
it whatever
and hey excuse me personal space little
important there I don't know if you know
about it
noted okay hang on wait no again I'm
just trying to do my job okay can't do
this I can't win that there's no way to
win oh okay all right so as drunk foo
masters I'm still sick so it's still fun
it's a little funny for me but this game
needs a lot of work and means uh use a
lot of love but I can see potential you
know being being obviously is going to
be compared to gang beats a lot it's not
always a bad thing but then again I
don't I don't even understand how this
works maybe the bots are tuned up real
hard has no idea but let me know what
you think down the comments below games
for free right now you can get the demo
done playing here and just let me know
what you think down the comments below
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]